Kansas State coach Bill Snider that's
here's a deep throw by Nicks got a man
lost it imperfectly it's caught
streaking down the middle of the field
and
it a pitch back and the toss up the
field and Franklin's
open Nicks quarterback run and then a
throw and then getting into the end zone
is Casey
Kelly against Travis J the for State
transfers Miss time with an E injury out
to his left down here one-on-one third
and two Nicks to the end zone and it's
into the arms of thank you Kevin forward
to hearing what Kevin and B have to say
at halftime on this big day of college
football Nicks strong arms it and with
these Troy friend another one-on-one up
here here with the Marian Cooper his
best
receiver he's going to run it Nicks
inside the five and inside the end zone
he can do it with the arm and then
showcase the smarts with the
legs under Center is Nick and the play
action for bonick lobs it for the End
Zone Terrence Ferguson touchdown
Oregon and with an experienced
quarterback he's just going to shred you
Blitz picked up Pump now a deep shot
bonick F cutting it back Troy Franklin
touchdown
Oregon between the tackles mix from the
pocket on the Move scanning throws back
end zone caught touchdown Patrick
Herbert it opened up very very nicely
easy throw from Nicks Forman Rush lots
of time launching downfield wide open is
Franklin good to see that he's standing
on the sideline third down and goal
Nicks he's going to lob one got a
one-on-one back shoulder Taz Johnson
touchdown to work we'll see if it pays
off in the fourth there's Nicks on the
move and launching downfield Franklin's
got it and he's dragged down inside the
15 de Irving remains in the game at
running back here's Nicks In The End
Zone touchdown Ducks Troy
Franklin couple times they've had some
excessiva oh Tess Johnson's behind Tess
Johnson gone you have to be patient
sometimes but this guy right here
special man I love sty five wide for
Nicks back shoulder throw he's got it
it's TZ Johnson TZ Johnson calling
Johnson touchdown offensive coordinator
will Stein who came over to take this
position getting to work with ls this
pass beautiful and it's toy Franklin
backing off as you said in front of keep
his feet Irving Remains the setb second
and goal over the middle caught
touchdown
Ferguson he really is a professional
mind playing the Collegiate quarterback
position I'll tell you what he said to
us yesterday in a minute this pass is
wide open and there's Franklin again try
Franklin get second and 10 versus second
and five before Nicks might not matter
Nicks enzone touchdown Troy Franklin his
12th Lo up the middle here come the sub
Devils Nicks going
deep another score for or Drew up an
Oregon Duck fan TZ Johnson and now
playing for this team and here's bonick
on the ramble into the end
[Applause]
zone trips at the bottom bonick rolling
to his right now he's got time to throw
across his body it dangles in the air to
Franklin touchdown
Oregon they only have two games with two
turnovers or more the Oregon Ducks all
year long free runner coming Nicks
heaves it and he had the
answer Nicks on second and three pum
fakes has some space pum fakes again
takes up B Knicks raming down the
sidelines has blockers all the way
down
Nicks scrambles fires in the end zone
low throw touchdown tering Ferguson for
the second time tonight Freeman Rush
Micks into coverage delivers over the
middle and squeez it in the Trac on
Holden Holden still running down inside
the
[Applause]
five